[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
hello everybody happy Friday welcome
GameSpot my name is John sorry yeah hey
my name is John Luke and I'm joined by
thirty four copies of Deal or No Deal
for the DES and behind these copies is
Joey oh there is
hey Joey how's it going hey everyone
it's Joey you're responsible for this
why do we have so many copies of Deal or
No Deal
that's a good very that's a very good
question so uh the reason why we have 34
is because it is the minimum amount of
Deal or No Deal copies I had to buy in
order to get free shipping at Walmart
because each of why these Wars was on
sale for a dollar in five cents yep and
uh you know just being the kind of
person I am I need to buy everything in
excess and so I got thirty four copies
and now we still out of focus we're good
yeah we're good we come with a great
idea to stream dealing No Deal these
copies of Deal or No Deal
ah so we won't be streaming every single
one of them that's probably going to be
for a later date there are two different
versions of this game by the way we
should make clearest so you have do a No
Deal 2011 special edition and then
there's somewhere one of these copies
just says this one just a special
edition it's from 2009 apparently this
one has new minigames themes and
graphics but you claimed there was no
difference they're pretty much the same
pretty much the same okay um so anyway
so what we will be doing today in
addition to actually streaming the game
we will be playing Deal or No Deal with
you yes so we're gonna be giving away
nine copies of Deal or No Deal and not
only every beginning of the way copies
of Deal or No Deal but we're gonna be
giving away other prizes as well yes we
will have a large assortment if you want
to go to the get to re-roll frame here
so here you can see all of the we're
gonna have a rotating list of all the
prizes here
like a copy of Gears of War judgment for
the 360 I was funny enough we have maybe
just as many copies of as we do so
actually in the chat Paragon the beasts
on YouTube chess 'king first explain
what Deal or No Deal is well we're gonna
play the game so we'll probably find out
how Deal or No Deal works for those of
you haven't seen the show by the way so
the way it's gonna work with the
giveaway is we are going to be we have
two chats we have YouTube chat wait the
twitch chat so we're gonna ask for both
chat so we're gonna make sure everyone
in each chat has a chance to win and
we're going to ask a Howie Mandel trivia
question about Howie Mandel whoever gets
it right first will have the chance to
play once you're playing no matter what
you're gonna win a copy Deal or No Deal
but then in addition you're gonna play a
miniature version of the game show Deal
or No Deal
to potentially win something better by
the way you have to be in the u.s. to
win so we're gonna make sure that you're
in the u.s. otherwise you won't be able
to get anything all right so let's get
right into the game Joey yeah all right
lovely music perfect so uh
okay so Deal or No Deal is basically you
have an assortment of 25 briefcases as
you can see in the bomb screen and each
briefcase is filled with a money amount
ranging anywhere from 1 cent to 1
million dollars and so at the very
beginning of the game the contestant
will pick one suitcase that they want to
believe that has a good amount of money
in it and so it will hold on to that and
every single round though they will pick
one suitcase open it up and that
suitcase will be eliminated from the
game now it could be like the first
suitcase you can open up could be a
million dollars you don't know you just
have to take that risk and hoping that
you you pick the good ones so at the
beginning you pick one case that you
keep with you the whole time Green is
the ID you want to pick you want that
one to be the million you want hopefully
that way okay you want to like assume
yeah and so ever every few rounds the
person known as the banker will come in
and he will offer you something he will
be like okay we see that you have
gotten rid of some of these high amounts
I'm gonna give you this amount you can
take like two hundred thousand dollars
right now and walk away with it or you
can keep going and try to win that
million right right and so it's like
this that's the whole No Deal Deal or No
Deal part of it because you can accept
it make the deal with a banker or you
can refuse it and say No Deal
keep going I want that million right
alright let's let's get into the game
here by the way I'm having trouble see
who became is all the coffee that you
get you can read it I can see it over
here on this screen bout that screen I
can if you accept the offer the game is
over
so enough talking let's play by the way
there's a rotating slideshow of all the
prizes yeah blow it right down here so
make sure to think about what you want
what you're hoping to win okay so it's
time for me to choose so I'm going to
choose one briefcase well no no the real
appeal of Deal or No Deal is that
tension right like the are you sure like
that back and forth between Howie and
the people and the audience and that
drama there's a lot of lack of that when
there's no stakes to this be in the game
try which is wishing well hey the people
the viewers will be the ones yeah
they'll be gives you guys want actual
stakes but maybe s game itself I feel
like it's pretty good okay then Asia
Beckwith says number eight eight so I'm
gonna go with number eight
Jessica's ship to Canada I believe its
us only but maybe get some confirmation
from Shiva if she happens to be in the
chat but I believe it's only us okay so
I'm gonna pick my first case to get rid
of you look people are shouting numbers
I know I'm gonna go with number 10 first
and hopefully I will be lucky $25 that's
pretty good so you want to get the lower
amounts here we go he's asking the
question by the way Shiva our social
manager will be helping giveaway the
prices is in the twitch chat she's
Khaleesi plays she says us only so sorry
oh [ __ ] you oh dude it's all downhill
from here Joey
well I can only uh that's about right No
who said number 21 who is that that
would be a Joe Kane 21 father name was
in it no man I hope that happens to
somebody okay we're gonna go with number
18 18 see I'm just gonna pick whatever
is the last one that's in the chat okay
hopefully you guys can help me out here
$5.00 Manny says he wants that game do
you said it's a good one yeah we put in
some you may notice there's a couple
stinkers and the prizes that's uh you
know like dealer note it wouldn't be fun
if they were all winners right no that's
that's the whole point
yeah whole point is is that you're
you're Riskin okay number two I see you
number two there so I'm gonna go well no
not number 17 are the controls they are
pretty awful I'm having trouble either
I can't use the touchscreen because it
then just selects it so I'm just going
with weird
the control oh my god number two come on
open it
are you right that was 200 grand dude oh
man what does the bank are gonna offer
you even like 120 bucks 20 bucks all
right I see number 13 go with number 13
hope [ __ ] no the Chet is just a series
of numbers at this point well that's
exactly what I expected all right
opening the case $300 thank you very
much
whoever said number 13 I believe it was
mr. MSS said that why is that Hannah
Montana one of the game one of the
prizes I don't think we had a copy of
would you like it to be Anna did we have
one I wouldn't be surprised if we did I
mean okay the banker is calling me hello
okay okay so he's gonna make me an offer
of $120 melt is the best you're gonna
get I mean we sure we should keep going
because the second it's a mindful
offering like there are only four cases
that have more money than that paragon
pieces you guys give away any PC games
SEC surprises no no PC games we have The
Sims 4 actually actually yes we do have
one PC game that is that is it okay so
what we'll do after I what the hell is
oh yeah so this game has minigames you
remember that party New Deal or No Deal
or well you have to break those suitcase
out of the block of ice yeah yeah I
totally remember that that's my favorite
part of the show
oh wow Mac dogs has some Deal or No Deal
emoticons Oh what that's awesome
all right I gotta find a way to let the
whole chat know how to use that on
Twitch please yeah were YouTube I don't
know if I came over to parently we
thought the whole thing no with the ice
game okay whatever okay the next one I'm
gonna go with number five I chose 17
though what okay there you go 5 Paragon
the basis was the PC game you guys give
it away we're giving away a copy of The
Sims 4 premium edition which by the way
apparently the that came just gonna have
a pretty big expansion this year so good
time to get into Sims 4 ok next up
number 6 I see a 6 there someone asked
what ps4 games we have we've got a
couple of ps4 games let's see here we
got got some Helldivers we've got
Assassin's Creed the Ezio collection
we've got tales of Bruce area
collector's edition all right next one
11
these are women have just $50 thank you
I was good someone earlier was asking in
the YouTube chat what the doom figures
are so they are like vinyl figures now
it's weird on the box it says mystery so
you know it's like you open it up and oh
I could get one of these 9 different
things but they all say cyberdemon on
them so i don't know if it's actually a
mystery box or not you might get 10
different mystery vinyls or you might
just get 10 cyberdemons who knows 1996
is too high there is no 96 on this on
this board number 4 I'll go with that
Alexander wants to know how do I win
so um later on after we do this run
through this game on the vs we're going
to have some Howie Mandel trivia facts
and whoever can get it right will get a
chance to play hello hello the phone is
ringing ooh see this is I'm glad I
didn't take the last offer because this
one's only got a better one okay it's
not still not as much as I'd like yeah
so I'm gonna go No Deal that's that's
usually what they do on the on the TV
show okay touch thought case - wow it's
just a shooting gallery no saying by the
way those doom figures are worth fifty
each now and you're getting ten of them
they're worth fishy says they're worth
fifty dollars you know so if you want to
get them all and like eBay that that's
like 250 bucks right there oh no that
might be more 500 Oh
bucks you can potentially get 500 bucks
just by selling those if you want
I mean I bet you know your thing - it's
like I'm on a roll here
so no I got negative 100 okay
cats are ladies Joey I'm tapping them
Alexander Jensen's asking is how we the
ball guy yes yes oh I can't get that one
you once know what's the trashiest prize
the trashiest as in like words of like
the worth of the prize is probably zero
or something uh sonic boom erisa lyric
which is up right now it's a good one
maybe that just depends on your
definition of trashy the Bulletstorm
cracker no that thing's the best at what
point are you ever gonna either a own a
nutcracker and be own one that's based
off of Bulletstorm one
okay next number please this has to be
the lowest so the socks it's um
Wolverine socks okay Sonic the Hedgehog
and mr. robot Fox one likes mr. robot
socks okay
DM says pick number nine if you want to
open that one up bring down the corrupt
government system you got to do it
alright see another 22 okay go with 22 I
wish I could see the person's name then
so this is whatever you do don't select
24 not 24 yeah they were saying that
that's gonna be they think that's the
750 750
and which one suits you Oh Thank You
Howie Breck subscribe thank you for
subscribing oh god the numbers are going
really fast I'm Joe Kaiser says number
15 who think comparatively though hmm
I don't know that was ten thousand
that's that's all right well so also I
guess another thing is in addition to
the potential price is one of them
actually just says nothing in which case
you only win a copy of Deal or No Deal
so I guess that's probably the worst
prize snappy Katz's number three little
bit up number three okay yes thank you
snappy yep
Jeff binder supremum is on them again in
another I'm getting the other offer here
it's gonna be at least to indicate or
eyes away only to the tribute winners
yes you have to win you have to get the
trivia right to be a person who can do
so I think the seal will keep going so
start searching up on your trippy facts
dude now I'm gonna go No Deal no do bent
on the right case to earn its money be
careful one of them is trapped those are
explosive in one of these okay guys body
parts everywhere I'll go with her these
are covered in blood at $200
this one right here $300 good wanted to
know how we got all these copies anyway
he said what set a pricing error no it
was actually on sale for a dollar
mario 64 was awaiting support or was it
it was a cheap-ass game she bout scam
video games at video game deals on
twitter and following them for oh no I
got the red bar without the trap no it's
paining me for some reason oh it's not
game over yeah that was the trip god
watch out for those red bars when you
notice how do you win prizes uh if you
can answer a trivia fact about Howie
Mandel you will get a chance to compete
for prizes oh no no my I say compete for
prizes you are guaranteed to get a prize
at that point it's just what prize you
get okay I see up game I can't read
named ray witness I think it says number
17 yeah well 17 more dollars you guys
are actually picking it really quickly
picking some really good numbers here
and very appreciative of it debar she
says number 7
oh it's nope number 7 number 7 is gone
those ladies over there MSS is number 1
2 1
all right you you think you got pretty
good on the last one so this one better
be good
yeah nice all right I'm gonna go with
goat Kip says number 19 cubase what's in
the doom box some vinyls ten of them you
get ten vinyls there's supposedly
mystery figurines yeah look at that look
at the entire first column is just all
gone except for one dollar okay so he's
gonna offer me probably 250
okay okay I'm gonna guess to 15 Dan a
joke ageless wait you're not supposed to
make the million dollars teepees so
you're supposed to pick out the
beginning at the beginning you pick one
suitcase let you hold but at that point
you're picking suitcases you want to
eliminate so in Joey immediately
eliminated the $1,000,000 yeah thanks so
whoever was at 12 in a row that weird
guy says twelve yes please don't be some
fifty whoo okay good good good excellent
double thumbs up there all right
you don't keep asking what's in the doom
box it's their vinyl figurines guys also
our thing just moved well uh oh whoa fix
that there oh we got jeez Ted the
saltshaker number 14 I think 14 is gone
okay goob number 25 oh no do not let me
down $400,000 I may need to come in and
help me fix this
mm it's gonna be less isn't it who is
this lady on the TV screens like every
time there's a different one
oh yeah I think the banker is just like
watching porn back there's like no deal
oh my time it's time to be a pretty
cushy gig right you just get to sit
there the whole time doing what uh I got
a deal okay all right
altaïr Drake says number 23 the number
23 really yes really will you be lucky
$1 that is the last one on the first
column cool someone's calling again
just move hey I got offered 340 thousand
dollars hey Matt Cain Mark W says number
22 oh we're done with number 23 okay
sorry technical difficulties days I'm
gonna pick this one myself since we're
working on the stream set but I'm gonna
go with number 20
cameras perfect never trust me to pick
my own cakes have this right this was
correct
we can look what we got Joey
I lost the $750,000 case oh well it
number wasn't it was number 20 I picked
that one myself okay so I was my fault
No Deal no deals in my vocabulary
perfect another minigame Janet's okay
for fixing us purple prizes cool oh man
I should pick number 26 I know I should
I shouldn't have left it up to my own
chat one at 26 apparently it's okay I
get some extra extra dough from these
ladies can I just not play this and like
lick a game down
let it go my favorite part about it is
it's a 60-second countdown but it goes
up to 60 seconds well I'm surprised that
the the clock hand is actually going the
right way right actually going clockwise
and counting up to 60 seconds for some
reason I can I'll probably deal it next
time after this last one because I don't
want to lose out on like a couple
hundred K because I know there's still
like a $50,000 prize somewhere or
twenty-five thousand okay goose is
hashtag praise day thank you new new
hashtag all right I'm gonna go with 26
you guys 126 well there you go
what was it that was five hundred
thousand dollars our D our offers are
just dropping Shiva we're gonna be
picking winners very shortly
right after enjoy your finish this game
we're gonna start playing with No Deal
okay I'm gonna go for the 300 K so let's
stick around people wait everyone
everyone was hoping for 26 but that was
bad so we got three left I'm gonna try
to oh my god
what's left
14:24 and then i think it's like what's
through wait oh I have the last one
nevermind okay it's either 24 or 14 see
what what do people say let's see what
are people saying first one says
fourteen fourteen eighty and Mudkip
Mudkip okay counting on you someone on
someone after that just keep 14 how are
you guys doing the DS screens we have a
really nice like actually it's not nice
like a giant giant orange box by the way
I lost my 300k
oh man that person who said that will
happen 300 was right it seems like the
banker wants to speak to me he's like
dude the [ __ ] happened man you messed up
Wow don't answer without a thought oh
good that's a good I think we got
arrested somebody that's kind of gamble
the whole way through at this point
we're the whole way there I either have
100k in my case or I have those other
150 thousand no I don't want to do this
just memory with money now it's really
slow to you like it takes forever for
the case is open
Joe canes to Stuart I don't even
remember what was in these anymore
Oh five dollars
okay no 300 was over here - so it's
three and four three and four okay
- four 10250 four seconds I'm done
see you sake okay you do I get to keep
that money
it's my consolation prize yeah Hellfire
double seven onion I will be gambling to
the end because that's just the person I
am
till I am completely broke do you want
to swap your case with the other this is
a big this is the big moment
let's see chat what are you saying I
swap it or do I keep it the M says used
cheat codes use the cheat codes just
came out she codes here Jordan this is
swap swap let's see let's get a couple
in here slop I mean like we got to first
usually when the key when they get to
when they get to this point in the
actual game show there you know the
person is like trying to go on with the
audience swap swap swap keep its I was
just saying 24 well that's the only one
that's left
I mean swap oh no no yes yes knowing
that jeez I'm gonna keep it okay yeah I
can't really get a sense of I mean I'm
gonna keep mine I had what are you gonna
get man I'm gonna go back home with
hello oh you have to hit it well I
didn't win account tax this is probably
the worst possible outcome
aside from I guess losing or I guess
aside from picking anything on the
thanks for joining us know guys so now
we're gonna be doing some do the
opposite of what he's safe
thanks scoop so we are gonna be like I
said we got two chats going we got
YouTube chat we got twitch chat so we
are going to be going I'm gonna get
would you like to turn down the this
wonderful dealer No Deal ten-second get
out of the way for a bit we'll get to
that in and back in a sec but right now
we're gonna move these out of the way
Joey why don't you grab that board over
there I'm gonna answer a question so one
this is GS Chad that's a good point um
we can make sure to check out the GS
chat for those in there that can do that
I'll pull that up in a sec we're gonna
start with a YouTube chat though first
so YouTube chats you got answer first
person to answer this Howie Mandel
question and you have to live in the US
so I'll keep an eye on it alright what
Howie Mandel is the creator and star of
what children's cartoon former star
former star no longer let's see not the
ready actually maybe we should oh we got
Bishop 303 I said I said YouTube Oh
YouTube drew strokes drew strokes okay
drew are you from the US maybe we should
turn on the music yeah we could turn on
something do you want it you want to get
a like some music going it's gonna be
the same thing
see a bunch people eventually responded
all right well we have already picked a
winner we gotta wait for Drew here if
that's the only problem is the the
twitch lag' or the lag Oh where's drew
I gotta get confirmation from Drew let
me scroll up a little bit make sure you
can get uh drew strokes
he's the first one yes we mm-hmm I am so
he is awesome all right drew
congratulations you won a copy of Deal
or No Deal you're also going to be
playing for potential prizes so drew if
you've had a chance to look in the chat
we want to know what prize would you
like to try and win we want to have a
goal you're gonna be shooting for so out
of all those prizes which would you like
[Music]
here we go
perfect
we're gonna real delay on the YouTube
chat here come on down come waiting
fabulous prizes
pump that pipe here we can look at that
potential press you can win a copy of
The Sims 4
or how about Assassin's Creed the Ezio
collection for the PlayStation 4 you
want to go for Assassin's Creed alright
that's this goal so weights gonna work
is one of these will have Assassin's
Creed one of these will have nothing the
rest will be completely random and
thanks for everyone in the YouTube chat
for helping us out no repeating it just
in case we missed the message there
alright
yep drew what case do you think has this
asin's Creed in it wonder done
a lot of people are saying frigid pick-6
juice called Oh
Thank You mrs. G S stands for game show
waitin to do here Mon drew
what's he picking
you see it and sits for let's see I got
to make sure that's that's the one issue
is for he said 40s okay number four so
he thinks for has it so we're gonna be
putting in here now start picking copies
to eliminates okay yeah sorry sorry chat
like it's very hard to for us to see the
chat horse right I've been reading this
at all we're reading
that's what he picks out
pictu eliminates six you have lost o the
nothing alright congratulations now
already eliminated the worst possible
option that was the the one cent option
here job good job man perfect perfect
alright next one
yeah the chat is a slightly slow so bear
with us while we get to the actual
answers okay Joe you have the ultimate
prizes yes occasionally Joey is gonna be
popping in I will be I will be playing
the part of the banker here
I can't rapid-fire guesses that's a good
point maybe to keep this going
drew why do you give us like a couple
things hey he could eliminate it's like
you said one said one okay yeah drew for
the next one why don't you pick a couple
of numbers to eliminate here's a word
judgment for the Xbox 360 all right
congratulations you can get that it's
okay
all right yeah the tension in this oh
boy
I like the music have some you zakone
right yeah I do all right
he said one he said one eliminate one
okay I can't pick a couple more
he says eight and nine eight nine okay
so we'll go with eight first first
Jordan asked how do you get picked to
play you have to answer a Howie Mendel
trivia question
Street Fighter the pixel pal figures so
not getting any of that number 9 is a
collection of socks sorry no no mr.
robot sucks for you it will be cold okay
let's see a couple others he's but he's
not gonna get cold feet about this
alright he's gonna he's gonna pick the
right ones here hit two more
gave goober meant lamenting the best
prize as some referring to the socks now
I mean dude the Nutcracker
actually Joey do you want to get in with
our deal with the banker or banker I'm
gonna go after this one since I've
already uh give him a thing we should
get in there a little bit yeah
so you pick out five in two okay we'll
go with five five five the DND starter
kids whoo it's looking pretty good for
him that that $1,000,000 prize is still
somewhere here and he lost the Naruto
Shippuden Ultimate Ninja Storm 4 road to
birudo for the Xbox one
ah Joey what will you give him if he
wants to walk away so right now we have
two cases left you have one or you have
a foot wolf number number four yep
number four is the hey we're hoping for
it's the magic so I'm gonna offer you
see if it walks away with it let's see
how about
I'm gonna offer you the Bulletstorm
Nutcracker all right you can walk away
with the Bulletstorm Nutcracker will you
accept the deal
no it's Deal or No Deal
let's see what he says you can have the
bolster Nutcracker right now you can
walk away with it or you can keep going
try your luck on these last two cases
all right a lot of times everyone's
cheering - I'm Andrew
good on you chat did you bring him down
make sure your nose Oh hidden he says no
deal
Oh deal all right he's not taking the
Bulletstorm nutcracker all right all
right room so let's eliminate one more
case does he death nuts need cracking
yep yeah Ashley C says the hell am i
watching you're watching Deal or No Deal
gamespot edition all right three and
seven some wants to know what's the best
place to play we're gonna be going back
and forth between the YouTube and twitch
channel we might also check out the
GameSpot chat if anyone else playing I'm
gonna go check that out right now
actually keep it out for drew see what
he says okay looks like he said three oh
we actually do have a couple people in
the chat can you scroll up a little bit
make sure you use on the screen make
sure you said three oh let's see six
someone's you said three let's see the
right
Oh
now that she saw uh I don't see Drew
sang three hope nope he didn't he said
three all right he's eliminating three
you're eliminating three so grab it all
right mouse and keyboard all right okay
mouse and keyboard that's a pretty good
one actually so now drew are you going
to keep number four or you gonna swap it
with seven you still got assassin's
creed right here in one of these one of
these one of these is assassin's creed
which is it all right let's see all
right Oh
GUP thinks he picked it good thinks he's
got it good things for is it let's see
some people are saying keep seven other
people saying keep four okay it is lucky
number seven but let's see come on drew
you got this I'm rooting for you is it
going no other offer this is no other
offer
no no says he'll keep four okay do we
want to find out what was in number
seven what stick it out I'm sorry drew
number seven was the Assassin's Creed
Ezio collection so let's find out what
you have won in number four you won Cave
Story for the Nintendo switch
congratulations
drew you want a copy of Cave Story for
the switch along with a copy of Deal or
No Deal for the DS congratulations
you're playing drew all right okay let's
get back over here we're gonna get right
going again with the next one Joey do
you want to for the twitch chat would
you like to pick a trivia question and
you can go ahead and uh yeah I'm gonna
start shuffling shuffle this back in
while Joey takes care of all this all
right so the next question for the
twitch chat here only for twitch chat
not YouTube Howie Mandel has a certain
fear he has an irrational fear of
something that's pretty well known what
is it
kid store one nor do I have somewhere
near in this file oh we got a winner
oh I think blind impulse he says germs
and that is correct
okay blind impulse congratulations you
are gonna get to play Deal or No Deal
with us blind impulse come on down okay
bye impulse what prize would you like to
win
thank you all right let's scroll down
and see what a blind impulse picked
Till's ps4 tails he probably is tails
tails tells Bruce area
all right cool yeah that's a good one
all right hey J Torres says he fears
people named Joey probably what reason
for that make sure I get that copy of
that in here
might have actually already put it back
so I'm gonna start putting them back up
here yep
okay just our reloading process yeah
sorry guys it's gonna take a second for
us maybe next time we'll have a
assistant little intern here okay
everything is in we're ready to play so
blind impulse what case do you think has
tails Bruce area we're missing number
nine mister number nine oh I'm sorry
Joey Joey we have too many copies of
yours no deal here I can't keep tracked
them it wanted out
I don't even know what to think anymore
I think we might be we might just be
losing our minds anyway what do you
think it couldn't be over there anyway
well it's just let's just keep going for
now I'm sorry this thing's uh okay he's
picking four in the lemon 89 well okay
so as for yes there's limited nine
Helldivers obviously it's not nine happy
nine you have 30 copies in front of you
hope you do not lose the copy of it
that's kind of true all right so the
copy that you have chosen is number four
I'm gonna keep it right here okay bye
impulse
look another copy to eliminate
my guess is that it okay so he says Lin
eat six number six okay and Assassin's
Creed the Ezio collection alright that's
pretty good alright alright let's get
another one just don't have enough
assists number one yeah ooh
Deus Ex mankind divided for the Xbox you
won't be playing it I won't be playing
it though alright pick next one alright
next one number three okay eliminating
at number three number three oh I am so
sorry number three was tales of Bruce
area collector's edition I'm so sorry
alright ring ring you have the banker
the anchor what are you gonna offer him
alright so you can either keep going try
to pick out a new a new prize or if you
want right now I can give you the
collection of sucks alright that is 3
sets 3 sets socks you get Sonic the
Hedgehog
Wolverine classic comic book Wolverine
and mr. robot socks right size between
shoe sizes 6 and 12 so most likely
you'll fit them as you can asses keep it
all right or D No Deal email deal
all right he says no deal he says
eliminate number five shovel knight for
the 3ds we gotta look for that nine
somewhere I know I'm okay he says number
eight sonic boom for the Wii U
congratulations congratulations for not
winning you're not winning that one okay
take another one all right we got one
more to pick before final number q is he
doing the exact same route that uh that
Drew was doing wait a minute yeah we
running on the same numbers I guess you
guess you thought those were good luck
okay what's the number to us for the 3ds
okay all right so the last one is number
seven I think you should ring I think
you should give me one more offer okay
I'll give you one more offer ring ring
ring are you gonna what are you know him
all right the last offer I'm gonna give
you you can either try your luck with
numbers 4 & 7 or you can walk away with
a copy of Gears of War judgment right
now
by the way here's a word judgment is
backwards compatible so if you have an
Xbox one
you can't play deal or no he says path
says no do deal alright are you going to
keep number four you can take number
seven Gupta says no love for gears he's
gonna keep gonna keep what was the
number seven number seven was just dance
for for the WiiU congratulations I'm not
getting that I'm not getting that I
imagine you don't you probably don't
have a Wii U I'm assuming and you got no
you didn't get that because that our was
already don't give me something randomly
we can't pick that one
is he gonna get what is he gonna get all
right cool
impulse you just won a copy of naruto
shippuden ultimate ninja storm for road
to burrito for the xbox one
congratulations all right cool keep
going
sorry about that we had a little
confusion where is number nine that I
think that is the most important
question right all right so sweet
regulations dude all right so I will
unload these so we're now gonna be going
over to the GameSpot chat if you want to
participate head over to WWE and spot
calm we're on the front page you just
click on participate in chat and then
you can play so chat there looks like we
got a couple people in there so are you
guys ready to answer a howie mandel
we'll see
they haven't answered in a while so I'm
not sure if they're still there it's if
they've all left already that's the
thing I can't tell someone says yes okay
they are here cool all right guys we
have some people in there
let's find a good one
Howie Mandel has appeared as a
spokesperson on television commercials
for what pizza what pizza chained in
Howie Mandel appear as a hired spokesman
for
okay let's find out no one's got it
right yet so this prize felt you going
corn corn Larkin said Boston Pizza that
is correct
Boston Pizza that's a deep cut right
there that is serve just the frame you
are in the u.s. downs name
that nine is gonna haunt me for a very
long time
by Chef says there's no such thing as
Boston peace wait what like like pizza
from Boston doesn't exist alright says
yes sir Tennessee awesome
congratulations so what do you want to
try and what do you what are you hoping
for a lot of people are talking to how
they've never heard of Boston Pizza
Howie Mandel probably hasn't either good
people are commenting Jeff vortex
comments that you said Boston Pizza so
we are rotating between the three
different chats we were actually the
next one we're gonna go back to YouTube
so it stick around on YouTube because we
are going to go back
all right we're just waiting from him to
find out I would take most of the prizes
he says tails are the Nutcracker why
don't we mix it up with the nutcrackers
since tails was the last one okay you're
gonna go with the Nutcracker make sure
the Nutcracker ends up in a box Joey
also make sure that nothing ends up in a
box oh yeah right so we got the
Nutcracker all right how we doing Jay
put tails in there as well duh since he
seems to seem to want that one let me do
that okay give me a chance okay
all right corn let us play a game of
Deal or No Deal with you pick a box to
eliminate
we don't have numbers since the number
nine mysteriously vanished that's nine
last one here is number nine it
disappeared into the void someone said
about the mouse and keyboard
[Music]
mechanical keyboard it's nothing super
special it's really generic very generic
keyboard weight on corn here to pick
some key school goes from the top he
says number seven so number seven is the
one you want to keep so number seven is
your one now pick
let's pick haven't pick two to eliminate
okay pick two - you want to eliminate
oops isn't if there were only pens paper
and tape in the office you might be able
to put them number nine somewhere let's
get rid of four and eight so number four
well we're picking why you start picking
some other ones to eliminate and keep
this moving faster tales for serie
unfortunately was number four sorry dude
Oh
heartbreaking wolf and then number eight
let's see here number eight is here's
the war judgments congratulations
graduations okay so if you're pol and
YouTube asks which chattery on currently
right now around the game spot chat over
on our site but we are going to be going
over to the YouTube chat for the next
one
all right just waiting to see what other
ones he wants to eliminate says let's do
five and then nine all right five is the
Sims for premium edition nothing
congratulations
all right so all right ring ring ring
what he got off him so as the banker
here I'm inclined to offer you copy like
you could you could try to luck with
these last four or you can take a copy
of Helldivers and walk away with it
right now The Nutcracker is still in
play you have the chance to win the
Nutcracker Deal or No Deal
let's see does
this is gonna consult the audience for
the next cue my shop says no one the
chat is old enough to remember Weird
Al's movie UHF I remember that movie I
actually never watched it as big of a
weed all families really nineties yeah
that seems right up your alley he says
no deal no deal okay let's pick two more
to eliminate
he says the audience to pick one in six
number one is Deus Ex mankind divided
for the Xbox one and number six six
let's see there's nothing in here join
congratulations don't worry about that
one
all right nothing again still good
though nutcrackers still in play so
we've got one more left I know I want
someone get that Nutcracker all right
one more it's either two or three
what you say he's gonna go with it's
gonna go three okay
what's three three is Street Fighter
pixel pal figures all right okay I think
we got one more offer all right so we
got two left
bring me ring
so you have number two left and number
seven you could right now walk away with
a copy of sonic boom for the Wii U
alright you can take your chances with
number two and number seven one of them
has the Nutcracker we could walk away
with this lovely game Deal or No Deal
okay let's see what he's gonna go with
says like those mau Odile and he's gonna
keep seven alright well is it number two
old boy oh my god number two was
Assassin's Creed the SU a collection
that means number seven no it is cracker
congratulations man
alright he wins the Nutcracker alright
dude awesome graduate we got our first
our first winner winner winner that's so
good Oh congratulations Koren over in
the GameSpot chat winning the Nutcracker
as gugus said the nut has been crying
that has been correct okay so we do want
to tally up the the winners so far we
have three winners yes we have a true
stroke from YouTube one came story a for
the Nintendo DS flying impulse on Twitch
one Naruto Shippuden burrito simple a
ninja storm or vertebrate oh-ho boy corn
Larkin on the GameSpot chat 1 The
Nutcracker
which is a Bulletstorm Edition it's the
most probably my favorite dumb thing we
have here so next we're gonna be going
back over to the YouTube yes ok ok let's
see what's everyone on the YouTube chat
listen up because we are going to be you
guys are going to be answering a trivia
question and the first person to answer
correctly will be able to compete that's
good ok ok
in the shut in the 90s show and 80s
actually and 9 news I guess in the first
two seasons of that show Muppet Babies
Howie Mandel voiced three characters he
voiced animal he boy Skeeter and he
voiced one more who was the last one
okay
Bobby's world is not correct
oh we got a winner we got where we got a
computing is the correct answer an op
303 just confirm you are in the US by
shop 303 come on down love that show by
the way correct but I'm a for moderate
so you might want to skip me ah well
it's like the next one then who is who's
next in one's a lot of people saying
after let's find out here something that
it was oh my gosh flaminia flaminia
let's go with Flaminia alright that was
the next person to say it uh Mia you are
in the u.s. correct
let's see here
gotta wait and gotta wait for the
response
and it was all filled up wait not
waiting to see what they got a way to
see response from them
I'm not getting anything yet I won't
give a second though because I know the
the YouTube channel yeah
yes nope nope nevermind that's different
I just saw the word yes
I guess I'm lookout cool I don't know
where they went
I don't see them a little bit are they
still here
oh no well whoever was said yay earlier
when we called out called out their name
Flamini oh I think okay I honestly did
not know how to pronounce it
she said no some people are saying no
she said she's in the EU oh okay well
let's get another question then doing
all right so far I'm sorry guys in the
all right let's let's go with remember
guys you have to be in the u.s. only
answer if you're in the US
okay here's here's a simple one what
city was howie mandel born in all right
and again we are still going with the
YouTube chat hmm yep
YouTube chat is fine right now
oh let's see you're getting some
Providence's but province is not correct
oh here we go I think this is the first
person its King James ooh all right it's
King James now you are the first person
to answer Toronto from us not Toronto
it can't be can't be living in Toronto
you actually live in Toronto sorry can't
actually live in Toronto a lot of people
are asking the YouTube chat how people
are answering before I ask I think
they're watching me the twitch chat
which one solicit but I think they're
watching the twitch one which has lots
of delay whoo
hot strats want me the list of a delay
in the chat right you owe a lesson delay
on the stream though I think that
YouTube one's a little bit further of
delay
okay - says he's from PA okay cool we
can play all right congratulation its
King James now you get to play what do
you want try and win you have a lot of
nice friend you want to go to the
overlay with all the prizes yeah oh
that's just the game there we go
some of these I should probably elevate
some of the
on King James I know you want those
socks oh he wants shovel knight on the
DS or 3ds all right I'm gonna stick that
in put that in one of them all right man
hope you get it okay get a couple more
in here all right
okay sir oh we would like you to pick
your case and then also pick one you
want to eliminate so which one you want
to keep him which do you want to
eliminate all right bring out the board
again
okay I says he picked number three
mm-hmm to keep pretty Kate he is going
to eliminate number seven okay
number seven let's see here okay since
for premium edition is out all right
let's pick two more to eliminate yes mas
fan my arm is very tired from holding
the site but it's a game show we do what
takes
okay he says eight and nine eighty nine
okay let's go on to number eight ever
oasis on the 3ds number nine the D and D
starter kits okay let me give them a
ring ring ring we can offer him all
right
so you took number three and there's
still five there's still five of them up
here shovel knights on there still I can
offer you right now the Kensington
keyboard and mouse and you can walk away
with this right now
or you can keep playing Deal or No Deal
so let's just change the guy who holds
we could hold it sometimes we get the
second one people are saying take it but
young it's a it's a pretty decent
keyboard that man you need to keep where
I mean yeah something you're always
gonna need he says no deal okay all
right man pick two more you want to
eliminate
is that a wireless keyboard no it's no
it's definitely not both of them are
wired definitely wired he says two and
six okay two and six see number two a
collection of socks I know that's a goop
the socks that's the one who wants
apparently you've already lost okay
and number six is nothing
congratulations
okay and once again thanks for everyone
in the chat for helping us out with
repeating the answers okay we're gonna
take two more to eliminate
rip sucks
yeah nice socks
I mean if no one wins them I'll probably
wear them I lose socks all but like they
just ripped something place right it's
like SF good good socks could always use
more socks
so we've got numbers one four and five
left and what's he gonna pick he says
one in four one in four okay one let's
see what one is oh sorry
number one was shovel knight' for the
3ds sorry my dude now on to number four
4 is the Street Fighter pixel pile
figures by the way those figures
actually glow like a they light up yeah
aren't you pretty cool I think you can
plug them in or something all right
ring ring ring ring ring okay man you
have lost a thing you were going for
let's see if the banker has a good offer
for you let's see
all right so you got you didn't get the
one that you were looking for but
there's number five here and there's
number three as in your hands you could
walk away right now the copy of
Helldivers with ps4 okay or you can keep
going
Deal or No Deal
it's King James
let's pick pile it to cool on twitch
says can either see my chat I can see it
that's all that matters trying to win so
no deal man
are you going to keep number three swap
with number five so far every person
that has played has kept the case that
they picked it's true
people want those socks that people are
just like please just send me those he's
gonna keep number three keep number
three okay what was in number five what
could you have won ah the ten doom vinyl
figures were apparently valued and
number three your prize is sonic boom
for the Wii U congratulations sir
congratulations King James or its King
James its King James now you win a copy
of sonic boom for the Wii U one of the
worst Triple A games in recent history I
can think of but the most fabulous prize
for you we're all very proud and of
course you also want a copy of Deal or
No Deal for the BS with it everyone who
wins gets copied Deal or No Deal
alright so let's kick it on over to the
twitch chat right then head over to
twitch yeah REE REE sort these boxes hey
twitch chat so is king james thank you
so much for playing and we'll contact
you about the wonderful prize just a
moment is a pretty easy one okay he does
the voice of a character in the hits
1984 film and it's 1990 sequel named the
series and the character Howie Mandel
plays
I see some people saying the character
but I need both the character and the
series guys saying both oh here we go we
got one got moss fan five six three five
six three all right the confirmed moss
fan five six three you are in the u.s.
correct
yeah
I am in the u.s. congratulations sir you
are in the US okay you get to play Deal
or No Deal for some prizes what would
you like Trent win
he says tails
alright so I'm gonna make sure that each
one of these is everyone's Oh keep
saying socks Allah be able want the hand
bitten to go for the socks right cube
thought it was an animated series or
something
now man's even gremlins is mo okay how
many more prizes are left let's see we
had 18 total four of them have gone
through so we're about working left yeah
we yeah we've got a couple that will be
given away so maybe eventually in a
future thing few might have a chance to
win them a big smoke on YouTube ask now
can you play
we're rotating through all three chats
we're gonna be doing each chat one more
time so yep just stick around and you'll
get another chance to win someone says
this is getting really cringey they look
bored I love it I'm not bored at all is
really we were waiting all week to do
this okay alright mas fan which case
would you like I loved keep this going
number two this is the case he's gonna
keep number two okay pick two cases to
eliminate
Nicholas Mitchell if you're wondering
what's going on here we're playing Deal
or No Deal
with the thirty four copies of Deal or
No Deal special edition for the DES that
I bought from Walmart smile sad number
three and number nine we're gonna start
number three here okay number three is
the ten doom vinyl figures okay I wanna
win those also I just want to know what
some deaf boy four five six
is it messed up that this is better than
the real show of course not oh yeah
that's awesome
oh the socks the socks have been
eliminated rip to the dismay of the
twitch chat I'm sure okay pick two more
so six and eight oh no tails Oprah's
area was number six I am sorry sir
Helldivers the ps4 it's good game ring
ring ring okay what he got for his
banker all right so you didn't get kills
for Syria the one that you wanted but
you could walk away right now with let's
go
let's go like this could walk away right
now with a copy of ever Oasis to the 3ds
or you can take your chance on the rest
of these Deal or No Deal see what he
says cool but says that tale shall be
mine
best of luck to you cool but you
thinking about it
people saying deal lobby we're saying to
you he says no DS there's no deal okay
two more to eliminate I see that the
twitch emote cons I love it up here
we got one four five and seven remaining
this is one in seven one was Gears of
War judgment for the Xbox 360
congratulation congratulation and number
seven was just ants for for the Wii U
okay now one more pick one more
oh thank you fat val kilmer that Belle
Kilmer says we both are beautiful
material oh thank you okay he says must
fans says number five grab number five
there see nothing congratulations okay
all right now I want to give one more
often banker bankers calling got number
four left and got number two left right
in your hands you could walk away with
that keyboard and mouse or you can keep
going try a look on these last two Deal
or No Deal
I'll have my headphones on so I don't
hear the music it's good it's very um
it's very repetitive he says no deal
since they are wired oh kappa okay
alright then fair enough fair enough
all right are you going to keep number
two or are you taking pork
he's gonna keep okay let's find out what
was in number four number four was the
DMD starter sets Lewis which means that
number two is Deus Ex mankind divided
for the Xbox one that's pretty good
congratulations nice all right
congratulations moss fan Deus Ex mankind
divided on the Xbox one
all right which means we are now going
to be moving over to the game spot chat
over at Gamescom you can check over the
chat on there looks like we got some
people in there nice ok so again if you
guys are wondering how to play we will
be rotating between the game spawn chat
the YouTube chat and the twitch chat
amaze you guys since is your closer on
that side okay sure
and any every the first person to answer
one of our Halle Mendel trivia questions
correctly will be able to compete so I
believe we've already gone through five
right yeah so we got four more left
[Music]
you on that one
yeah I should word that one just okay
yeah so Howie Mandel in the late 90s had
a syndicated talk show called the Howie
Mandel show how many seasons did it go
for it this is worthy GameSpot's chance
one of the moderators sends it
okay cool
Val 7x says one vowel are you in the US
yep connect it cool on graduation
congratulations sir
you get to play do you want No Deal
what would you like what are you hoping
again I'm gonna head over to our
rotation surprises here so much have
been eliminated
Wow sadness or actually not sadness yeah
pretty happy that pretty happy that
someone song boom he wants to go for
Doom all right good good all right
got them almost all in there
awesome ready to go okay
all right Val which case would you like
to keep and also then pick one you want
to eliminate make it go
says keep setting lucky number seven
like an episode I guess so
lemonade - okay goes into Knutson - choo
is the Street Fighter pixel pal figures
I think are pretty cool watching all
right all right Val pick two more all
right they say three all right see
what's in three three is every sis for
the 3ds number eight number eight is
Helldivers for the ps4 ring ring ring
all right thanks for Joey what do you
have on offer banker here so the well
which one did he request the doom
figurines or figurines is somewhere on
this board or in your pocket you could
keep going or you can walk away right
now with a collection of everyone's
favorite Oh socks the socks on I'm I'm
giving you a chance to walk away with
these socks you could walk a walk in
them
Deal or No Deal
that's gonna take so yes we're looking
at all three chats
tl man says ring ring is so cringy well
how else is a telephone supposed to
sound like
come on all they say no deal
alright alright pick another case then
or pick to pick two cases the goop is
very excited about the socks I mean who
wouldn't be
I don't know if we want to offer that to
anyone the church dad they all seem to
just want it I know you do a lot of
people ok says six and one so is six
here number six the keyboard and mouse
okay number one
Just Dance 4 for the Wii U nice two more
two more CEO man says eat the socks you
could fibrous material digestible
five and nine yay number five see here
ah the ten doom vinyl figures was in
number five so sorry number nine is the
nothing alright well that's good you're
gonna win something nobody has won
nothing yet
yeah I'm happy for that you'll get a
copy doing all right one last chance
banker yes I will do there is no other
telephone noise ring so got number four
and number seven left
no more doom figurines but you could
walk away right now with a backwards
compatible version of Gears of War
judgment for the 360 all right Deal or
No Deal
laval pick No Deal okay deal
would you like to keep number seven or
take four instead it always ends with
really yeah they thought there was a
three last time maybe but like forty
sevens been in multiple times goods in
ranking the prizes for himself he says
socks are number one dude figures or two
and threes the mouse keyboard equals
same for people saying seven let's bow
gonna bake now pick seven all right let
me make sure that he wants to keep
number so you're keeping seven yes seven
is what you're keeping dizzy death says
top prizes won socks yes they're keeping
seven okay cool what sighs oh this is
for premium edition that's pretty good
alright see what they've okay which
means that you they won't have one
shovel knight for the three TS
congratulations Val all right good job
thank you very much for playing alright
we're now going to be heading back over
for the last time to the youtube chats
get rid of YouTube
alright alright so we'll make these uh
the last round trivia a little bit
harder okay lardo
all right let's see who really wants
people done not the socks and those
socks are gonna be in there every single
time you know that right yeah
okay so Howie Mandel starred in two
episodes of the hit TV show monk took
place right here in San Francisco what
are the names of the two episodes you
need to name a name both both of the
episodes Wow stop and once again this is
for YouTube chat right your chat
keep an eye on the chat
well it looks like we got the winner
well we got a winner oh dear God run
that's a good name I like that says uh
mr. monk joins a call and mr. monks
100th case oh dear God run are you from
the u.s. given out for me Joey I like
how boys just like time to hit up that
IMDB I mean how else you gonna know
these unless you are a real big monk and
or how we Mendel famine no huh
I was pretty big Munson and I just went
on response from oh dear God run
they say yep they're in the u.s. awesome
congratulations you get to play do or no
deal with us what would you like to win
what are you hoping for he says he's
from Maine from Maine nice awesome a lot
of people are saying take the socks
resume the socks
you got everything else in got a couple
before you are the main man I like that
they said the Ezio collection cool nice
alright so we got everything else yep
throw a couple more in
okay okay come on Joey sure thing
alright oh dear God run are you ready to
play Deal or No Deal
all right so tell us which case you
would like to keep and pick one to
eliminate off the start
got the board back up here
what'll it be all right
oh thank you
waiting what was his name again oh dear
God run oh dear God run he says keep -
okay eliminate for oh I like it - we're
getting rid of more let's see what
number four was number four was Gears of
War judgments congratulations
alright two more
meanwhile we have a hell even the
virtual howie mandel over him he's just
kind of standing there waiting for your
voice waiting yeah jeopardy or Wheel of
Fortune Court giveaway oh man we got we
will figure it we'll figure something
out in the future got to get rid of all
this stuff somehow he says get rid of
one one in big feet rid of one see here
ah Congrats one was the nothing you're
definitely gonna take away a prize sone
says they came here for the clickbait
thumbnail I don't know that's a
clickbait thumbnail ELISA is how we men
don't click baby you what's worse than
nothing dies are the Gears of War
judgment something number eight was The
Sims 4 premium edition yeah I'll give a
ring I'll say hello still got a lot of a
lot of good prizes up here pick number
two but you could walk away right now
with the Street Fighter pixel palace
fighters okay and these do light up they
they look or they they're Ryu and
chun-li mix without melee it up Deal or
No Deal
see the the rotation of prizes down
there will probably come up eventually
as you can see it they say God run
people are talking about the the delay
for the chat won't write about how long
a typical dealer No Deal episode elastro
they could be on that they could be on
that a at stage for like an hour maybe
and that's for just one person
so I wants to know if they won the at Co
collection and no that's thought that's
the look okay he says those look nice
but he's gonna say no deal
alright go ahead pick two more for who
for oh god dear Raj Oh Sanskrit that's
agree that's when they were going for it
cool
don't they get it a lot of you but we're
going for Assassin's Creed hope someone
get something maybe cut back to the big
ones big ones so you can see the board
yeah here we go
it says three okay number six was Oh
sasses Creed the Ezio collection I am
sorry
whomp-whomp
all right then free let's see what else
three was Helldivers for the ps4 all
right we got it's gonna pick two more
take two more cool stuff though and
you're guaranteed to win something oh do
you already get rid of than nothing
nothing was he's already been gotten rid
of we got five seven and nine left nine
does not have the number because howie
mandel somehow made it vanish from this
room
all right
how's your Friday Joey it's going well
yeah he's loving this live stream Deal
or No Deal
okay oh dear God run says number seven
and then fine let's see number seven is
the ten doom vinyl figures whoo yeah
that's a good one and number five the
DMV starter kit okay so now you are left
you want to give one more offer yeah
I'll give you one more offer you are
left with number nine and number two but
you could walk away with that nice
little keyboard mouse okay right now you
don't need to worry about possibly
winning nothing or you know witness all
of the Deal or No Deal
that's the big question
couple be on the chat we're asking yes
the twitch chat will be up next
his I once ever they got the board no
this is a this is a former picture frame
for a poster that I just took out of
here
what does a keyboard look like I can
grab it
oh wait well he says no deal he'll he
has a laptop but just for everyone else
mouse keyboard nothing too special but
you know solid mouse keyboard okay
so the last question is do you want to
eliminate number seven or no number nine
I'm sorry number nine and keep number
two heat number two or do you want to
swap was it gonna be
so let's connect can't connect to other
things a mouse a keyboard
technically yes different computers with
a USB okay so he says I'm using a
keyboard right now is it good
you can vouch for it well he already
said no deal okay I'm just curious now
quality this keyboard
all right oh dear Gudrun where's that
with us he dumped you
oh dear God run waiting on his final
answer that's a different game show by
the way
so it's gonna keep - okay all right
number nine
what was it number nine Oh number nine
was the socks Oh
number nine what's the sighs all right
now what is it number two
Bishop 303 says he would have squished
nine he would have gotten the song but
he got in the socks you win a copy of
Just Dance 4 for the WiiU
congratulations now congratulations are
in order out all right
thanks for playing oh dear God run you
will be getting your prize a copy of
Just Dance 4 for the Wii U and dealer No
Deal special edition for the Nintendo DS
okay so we've got two more left two more
left
we're on to the twitch chats you're
ready twitch
I want me do this yeah I think I will
refill these it was 28 29 29
Oh Howie Mandel voiced the lead
character named a little Howie in what
video game and once again this is for
the twitch as orange which you have to
be in the u.s. to weigh all right which
let's see what they got
oh we got a winner oh all right
[Music]
Belva near filthier fell fear says to
Land's just confirm you are in the u.s.
correct
that's quick
and says yes sir congratulation nice
alright you're gonna be pulling dealing
No Deal what would you like to win let's
go to our rotating list of games I got
to eliminate a couple here now
we still got Assassin's Creed the D&D
starter kit the doom figure he wants go
forever oasis okay every way so sweet
cool alright a lot of potentials here
yeah so people wondering the options
still up for potential prizes as
Assassin's Creed the D&D starter kit the
doom figure after oasis here's a word
judgment Helldivers the mouse and
keyboard the socks the very famous at
this point socks the Street Fighter
figures tales of Bruce area and the Sims
or
okay
okay all right all right
please pick which case you would like to
keep and what you want to get rid of
first let's talk fighter figures I'm
allergic to all these copies with Deal
or No Deal okay he says keep number four
all right
I was asking no more Twitter YouTube yes
switcher YouTube no more but if you want
another chance to win you can head over
to to GameSpot chat over at a WWE games
be calm
do people still use WWE not when I like
saying it it's confused number two that
you eliminated was EDD starter kids
all right pick Jim or someone say what
color are the socks so much they said
percentage which I assume means 5 5 5
and 8 yes so here's the first sock Sonic
the Hedgehog socks and rings on them and
we have Wolverine x-men socks those ABS
on them look horrendous I would wear it
finally mr. robot socks great Joe all
right
number five and eight number five five
is these Street Fighter pixel pals
pretty good one yeah and number eight is
SAS escribió collection no one's won
that okay yeah I will make an offer here
so we still got a lot of good games out
up here lovely prizes including the one
that he wants right ever Isis he wants
offer you right now a copy
of the sims 4 premium edition oh you
could walk away with this right now or
you could keep going you could keep
trying to win 21 what do you say Deal or
No Deal he says no deal okay I thought
that I thought that could get them all
right that's pretty good one moving on
to the final then you're to enjoy no gas
canister says how is that tape still
sticking it's honest last legs I would
say good thing we'll have one more after
this one and nine all right number one
we have oh I'm so sorry ever Oasis
number one and number nine here's a word
judgment that's always a win it's always
a win when you delegate your judgment
okay it's just maybe oh sorry I felt
there he says no heartbreaking all right
two more like two more two one eight
says a three and six all right okay
number three nothing congratulations and
number six is oh the socks so close okay
all right
get one more offer one more offer here
this seems to be a running theme for my
offers but now that you don't have ever
Oasis for 3ds on the board anymore I can
offer you a ps4 copy of Helldivers Deal
or No Deal
see what he says
No Deal deal okay would you like to keep
number four or would you like to take
number seven oh dear God
run wants to know which Just Dance they
won you won just dance for for the Wii U
so I hope you have a Wii U he's good Oh
Bell theory he's gonna swap it Oh first
mom okay let's find out what's we take
this one put on the the podium right
there there you go now your case we're
gonna find out what's in number four and
when you have the whole time was the
mouse and keyboard what you had with you
the whole time now final one what you
win is oh dude you got the ten doom
final figures whoo
Brad I think that that might have been
our biggest win so far um I took the
Nutcracker because they actually okay
yeah on it that's right that was pretty
good one congratulations for winning
contender
vinyl figures along with a copy of Deal
or No Deal special edition
congratulations congratulations all
right now we're going to go into the
last chance to win something for today
over in the GameSpot chat so head over
to gamespot.com if you want to try and
win something
all right misery cord says I just popped
in to say this absolute genius guys keep
it up thank you we uh we workshop this
idea for a good amount of time I think a
little bit longer than we should have
probably but I'm glad people are
enjoying it and glad you guys are here
watching us and participating winning
some great prizes too okay so I'm gonna
give a couple people chance to get ready
in the chat last question yeah sure have
a good one here all right let's take a
look you want to keep these as the yeah
these will be the okay all right
let's give me a chance put me in coach
head over to well it's the chat goob all
right got a couple people Canadian
Mudkip says they need this as long as
you're not from Canada Canadian Mudkip
and your girl okay okay so this one's
going to be a Deal or No Deal
trivia question I just want to make sure
I have
fairly very involved question
okay looks like we got a number of
people ready in the chat over in the
GameSpot chat I'm just gonna go with
what was on his paper okay all right so
Deal or No Deal Howie Mandel has been
the host of it since 2007 but the
American version wasn't the first
version to come up whoa which country
had the very first version of Deal or No
Deal Oh a pie shop West High Mendel
social security number and go
no it was it did I flub the question
okay actually I'm sorry I read it wrong
you're right it wrong
ah Joey you read it wrong I could
everyone that okay I'm gonna go with a
question all right let's go with
oh actually okay this might be the most
obscure thing on our list okay so after
gain expelled from his high school he
because he impersonated a member of the
school board and scenic was it he was
expelled from high school and Howie
Mandel went on to become a Salesman what
did he sell Wow
that's a question Joey oh wow we already
got someone in there
riah one one three says carpet salesman
all right congratulations
right you are from America correct
no John J did in the twitchchat he did
not sell pornos crazy pink who says
socks obviously yes naturally
okay yes they are in the u.s. all right
congrats wonderful okay all right you
were gonna play dealer no deal with us
what would you like to win
we have Helldivers Assassin's Creed says
surprise he was a human trafficker no
that is not correct the GND started kid
ever Oasis the always popular Sox Bulls
their name again
Ryan they would like Assassin's Creed
okay going for assassins P I hope
someone hope you get it
I hope you get us a screen alright
oh dear God run says luckily he can't
win Just Dance I mean that's that's the
kind of risk you take when I have up
play Deal or No Deal all right got
everything loaded in almost son says he
wanted to play rip GameSpot account
creation they're probably trying to
create in town oh do you make that
account next time we do this you'll be
ready cops for everyone everyone go make
GameSpot accounts oh boy here it is the
last and final board of the day they're
shooting for assassin sock 3's auxins 3
no please don't please don't
does that mean as a chat okay what would
you like to see would you like to eat
and then pick one to Alameda
Oh son says a calculation wasn't working
surfers to something that's about where
everyone's trying to make make an
account yeah they're all trying to it at
once hundreds of thousands of people
well if you can't get if you guys didn't
make it into the one of the contestants
as one of the contestants
feel free to cheer the final one on as
they go for the Assassin's Creed 4 they
are keeping recessives Creed 4 ps4 Ezio
should be six let's see if six is the
magic magic number alright eliminate two
dizzi death says i have an eternal void
in my soul where the sock should be
this is eliminate - okay all right there
it - I pick another one to eliminate as
well all right you got rid of the sims
for premium edition there's pretty good
one lerton off great
no one's winning that tonight nope no
one's winged that all right let's get
rid of two
all right pick two home lemonade four
and eight okay let's see here
before is every way sis three D F so no
one is going away with ever OS and
number eight is the nothing
congratulations you will definitely win
a prize
alright banker time alright so we offer
them you got rid of nothing you still
got the at sealed collection up there
somewhere still good but you can walk
away right now
nice D&D starter kit pretty good yeah
you're doing taking D so Deal or No Deal
see what they say oh damn saying no deal
deal okay right then pick two more to
eliminate
three and nine three nine okay
Oh year number three is hails of force
area collector's edition oh that's a
good one
Oh what's a good one ones getting that
tonight though and then one nine Oh
Congrats you did not want a copy of
Gears of War judgment means we still
have that's so many copies of that in
the game library I don't know why kinda
said that we didn't just put all just
fill them with Gears of War different
copies okay two more a crazy thing that
the socks are still here somewhere
actually well I'll save this
all right one and seven okay what's the
number one number one is Street Fighter
pixel power figures okay no one's
getting those and number seven is
Helldivers for the ps4 Wow okay secrete
is still on the board it could be these
two but we have one more call from the
banker hello
I see you have Assassin's Creed the echo
collection somewhere in one of these two
cases but you could walk away right now
with a nice collection of some Oh
tempted I'm with the Sox dealing them
with the Sox Deal or No Deal they're
gonna get socks you're gonna get
saturated
they're gonna get something else
skin tense way they say they said
tempting but no deal they didn't need
the socks all right okay are you going
to keep number six which could have
Assassin's Creed or do you think it's in
number five which is it which one do you
want
No Deal in this house mouth wow man
they're going for it that was asking how
is that even possible
people are saying switch people are
saying keep oh man they're keeping
keeping it okay alright in number five
oh man oh I'm really glad this was last
one this is so down to the wire Joey
what is it gonna be
let's find out and it's the mouse a
keyboard which means that means number
six is Assassin's Creed the ETSU
graduations you did it that was Joey
pretty amazing Congrats
I'm sorry cuz Rhea Rhea one one three
you got it oh my god that is the that's
the perfect way we could have ended this
is very nice that is so awesome
that is cool man well congratulations to
all of our prize winner you say are you
sure it doesn't say socks on there that
is thanks everyone who played drew blind
impulse Corrine its King James now mas
fan Val oh dear God run Fez near I think
and felt near Andrea all the one
fabulous prizes today some more fabulous
than though there's no more fabulous
than others I think it thinks to all the
winners and all also everyone in the
Chad who participated in throwing out
numbers and suggestions for the people
playing thank you for letting us do this
and yeah maybe we'll do something else
like this some other time I know I'm not
sure how many other games show video
games that will incorporate right into
our Friday streams but we will be here
every Friday every Friday um and we'll
also be streaming on games fall on
YouTube on Twitch every day as well
every weekday so make sure it's stay
tuned for that subscribe to us when you
have the chance and we will see you
next week